et le point justement sur cette
situation avec notre reporter ali la
faam ouzou depuis la prison de fleury
mérogis dans l'essonne
face à la gravité de la situation
sanitaire le personnel pénitentiaire de
mont tout simplement la réduction
drastique de la population carcérale en
aménageant les peines de courte durée ou
celle des détenus âgés ou en remettant
en liberté les personnes qui sont en
détention provisoire pour l'instant ce
personnel a l'impression de ne pas être
entendus par le gouvernement je propose
d'écouter cette représentante du
syndicat ufap unsa
ça fait à peu près une quinzaine de
jours que nous avons alerté
l'administration sur cette situation
nous préférons toujours agir en
prévention que dans la réaction c'est
exactement ce que nous avons fait
puisque malgré les annonces différentes
du président ainsi que du premier
ministre
c'est seulement aujourd'hui que nous
avons arrêté tous les parloirs ainsi que
les activités alors que nous demandions
d'abord une réduction de ceux-ci pour
pouvoir empêcher une propagation du
virus à l'intérieur de la maison d'arrêt
puisque nous ne savons pas comment cela
peut se passer dans un espace confiné
nous ne souhaiterions pas que ni les
collègues ni les personnes détenues ne
soit atteinte
donc il nous a fallu attendre
aujourd'hui pour que nous soyons enfin
entendu même si cela reste encore très
peu puisque il ya des gels qui ont été
livrées il y a des gants certes mais il
manque encore pas mal de matériel comme
les masques au cas où il y ait une
infection qui qui commence pour que nous
puissions être protéger les personnes
détenues comme les surveillants
pénitentiaires et leurs familles pour
limiter la propagation du là pour
limiter la propagation du virus
la garde des sceaux nicole belloubet a
annoncé la suspension des parloirs pour
les familles et les proches des détenus
une décision difficile à accepter pour
cette femme de détenus que nous avons
rencontrés devant la prison
malheureusement ils ont refusé de nous
rentrer malgré que j'aidais confirmation
par mail j'ai appelé ce matin ils m'ont
confirmé aussi deux parloirs pour
le 23 et le 20 et le 23 et malgré ça y'a
personne qui rentre il n'y a pas de
dépôt de lège on peut rien savoir qu'est
ce qui se passe à l'intérieur
mon compagnon il avait la grippe la
semaine passée il ya à peu près dix
jours il a demandé l'infirmière et
jusqu'à je pense jusqu'à maintenant il
n'ya pas y'a pas de réponse parce que il
a demandé avant aussi ça prend du temps
pour le médecin le voit dans ce contexte
anxiogène où le virus se propage à
grande vitesse
rappelons le plus de 7000 cas en france
les familles de détenus mais aussi le
personnel pénitentiaire ont l'impression
d'être les grands oubliés du
gouvernement